LEE YANCO: Hey, everybody.
Welcome to App 203,
introducing our new managed
service for Prometheus.
My name is Lee Yanco.
I'm a Product Manager
within Google Cloud.
I'm joined today by Bartosz
Jakubski, Senior DevOps
Engineer at OpenX.
So today we're going to
talk about some challenges
with Prometheus, we're going to
introduce Google Cloud Managed
Service for Prometheus,
do a bit of a deep dive
in the components of the system,
talk about how it compares
to cloud monitoring,
and then OpenX
is going to talk
about their journey
with managed service
for Prometheus.
So, challenges with Prometheus.
Prometheus is great.
It works really well.
There is a very good reason
why it is the de facto standard
for Kubernetes monitoring.
Managing Prometheus for small
deployments is pretty easy.
Managing Prometheus at
scale can be very hard.
So first of all, Prometheus can
be hard to scale horizontally.
When you have a small
cluster, you just
put a couple of gigs of RAM in
the server and it just works.
Your cluster gets
a little larger,
you have to scale up by
throwing more RAM at the server.
Eventually your
cluster gets so large
that you have to shard
by frontend application
and backend application
or by A through M and N
through Z or
something like that.
Somewhat interestingly for
a cloud-native service,
Prometheus doesn't have a
particularly good horizontal
scaling story.
Prometheus can be
hard to make global.
So when you're small and you
only have a few clusters,
it's no big deal.
You have a couple of different
data sources within Grafana,
you swap between them, it works.
Eventually you might want to get
a global view, so you federate.
Eventually your Prometheus
deployment grows even more.
So you have multiple
federation servers.
You might simplify it
by switching to Thanos.
So you have Thanos querying
your Prometheus servers.
And then you go
hybrid or multicloud,
and you have Thanos querying
Thanos querying your Prometheus
servers.
And then somebody
on your team adds
user ID or IP address as a
label, cardinatily explodes,
and the whole thing falls
over, which leads me
to my third point--
managing Prometheus
can be an ongoing operational
burden and a thankless task.
Your end customers
do not care how good
you are at managering/monitoring
infrastructure.
They care how good you are at
keeping your app up, of course.
But the monitoring
infrastructure part
is really a thankless task.
None of this is hard,
it's just toil, it's work.
It's 20 to 30 hours of
somebody's time, every week,
in perpetuity.
Here's the thing.
Google has been through
this exact experience.
10 years ago, we
also had a system
for monitoring where we
had local servers that
federated into
regional servers that
federated into global servers.
We built some new
technology for ourselves
to solve this
problem for Google.
And we're excited to
share this next-generation
Prometheus-compatible
solution with you.
So we're introducing Google
Cloud Managed Service
for Prometheus, a drop-in
replacement for Prometheus
and Thanos.
This is the managed service
for Prometheus ecosystem.
I'm going to use this
to frame a conversation
about the different
parts of the system
and how they benefit
you as a customer.
So in the center sits Monarch.
Monarch is Google's planet-scale
time-series metric storage
and retrieval database.
Monarch is the same
exact system that we
use to monitor internal Google.
So ads, search,
networking, YouTube,
Google Play, you
name it, all use
Monarch to make sure
that their apps are up
and running and stable.
We have a separate instance of
monarch called Cloud Monarch.
Cloud Monarch is the
same instance that's
used by Cloud Monitoring.
And Managed Service
for Prometheus
shares some of these
cloud monitoring APIs.
And I'll get back
to why that's super
interesting in the second.
On the left side, we
have the collectors.
So our collector is compatible
anywhere that Prometheus runs.
Because our collector
is Prometheus.
It's Prometheus plus a
couple hundred lines of code
that wrap things up in a
proto and send it to Google.
So we have two different
types of collectors.
So the self-managed collectors
use your existing Prometheus
operator configs to
configure the scraping.
So you just copy-paste
those, switch out the binary,
and they just work.
If you're in GKE, we also
have managed collectors,
in which case Google will handle
the scaling, the sharding,
the deployment of
these collectors.
And you configure the
scraping using CRDs.
On the query side, because
we have implemented PromQL,
your existing Grafana
dashboards written in PromQL
just work, your Prometheus
alerts and alert manager
configs just work, and
your PromQL-based tools,
any PromQL-based
tool that you might
find on the internet, any
community-curated dashboard,
any random alert template you
might want to use, just works.
And because we're using the
same APIs and backend systems
as Cloud Monitoring,
your Cloud Monitoring
metrics-- your free
metrics, your free BigQuery,
your free Anthos, your free
Istio, your free Dataflow,
your free Pub/Sub,
whatever you use,
those metrics will be
accessible within Grafana
using PromQL, right alongside
your Prometheus metrics,
giving you a single
pane of glass.
And likewise, because we're
using the same backend system,
your Prometheus
metrics will also
be available within
Cloud Monitoring.
So you can use advanced features
such as SLO alerting, cloud
alerting, our Dashboard Builder,
et cetera, with your Prometheus
metrics in Cloud Monitoring.
We built this to be as drop-in
of a replacement as possible
so that you can keep
doing what you're doing
and just outsource the hard
part, the metric storage
and retrieval part, to us.
Now let's do a bit of a deep
dive of some of the components
here.
So let's talk about Monarch,
the planet-scale in-memory
time-series database.
It's the same tool we use
to monitor internal Google.
Monarch has over a trillion
time series in RAM,
14 quadrillion points on
disk, writes 2 and 1/2
terabytes a second, processes
16 million queries per second.
Whatever you can throw at
us, we can handle, promise.
Monarch is configured for
two-year retention, included
for all metrics by
default. And Monarch
has regional storage with
ad hoc global aggregations
at query time.
So if you say you want your
data to live in cloud zone x,
your data will live
in cloud zone x.
On the collection side,
we're compatible anywhere
Prometheus is deployed.
There's two flavors,
managed for GKE environments
and self-hosted for other
Kubernetes environments.
This means that managed
service for Prometheus
is hybrid- and
multicloud-compatible
from the very beginning.
Our collectors are
open source, so you
can see what's running within
your clusters of course.
And there's no need to
store any data locally.
So you can use way less
RAM to run these collectors
than normal Prometheus.
On the query side, we're
fully PromQL compatible.
So your existing Grafana
dashboards just work.
You can query your
free GCP metrics
alongside your
Prometheus metrics,
getting you a single
pane of glass.
And read permissions
are enforced on groups
of projects at query time.
So this is really
nice for customers
that have tenants of their own.
So you can do something
like send tenant 1's metrics
to project A, send tenant
2's metrics to project B.
And then you have a
separate permissions
that has both project A and
B included for your SRE teams
to get a global view
across all your tenants.
On the alerting and
recording rule side,
we work with Prometheus
Alert Manager out of the box.
We work with PromQL-based
alerts and recording rules,
anything you might
have developed already,
out of the box.
And we are compatible
with Google Cloud's
alerting as well.
So as you can see here, we
built an interactive query UI
within Cloud Console.
You can see this is
working software.
This is me querying
Prometheus metrics.
And you can see them
returning to the screen.
We also have full
Grafana compatibility.
So you can see this is
me just changing the data
source from local to foreign.
And it just works.
Nothing changes.
So this is great for you as
a customer, terrible for me
as a presenter.
Because really
nothing should change.
When you swap from
your local Prometheus
to Managed Service for
Prometheus as your data source,
it should be exactly
the same data.
And that's what you're
seeing right here.
So let's do a brief comparison
with Cloud Monitoring,
because we do now have two
products within the same area.
So there are two products
coming out around the same time.
There's Google Cloud Managed
Service for Prometheus, which
is Google's recommended way
to run Prometheus at scale,
and there's Cloud Monitoring
and the upcoming GKE Workload
Metrics, which is
Google's recommended way
to monitor Kubernetes
applications.
So maybe another way to
think of this might be,
if you, as a customer, if
you're saying to yourself,
you know what, I don't want
to deal with any monitoring
infrastructure
whatsoever, I want
Google to manage
everything for me
and I want to get the best
practices of Google monitoring
and Google SRE's philosophy
built into my monitoring
infrastructure, then Cloud
Monitoring and GKE Workload
Metrics is the product for you.
If you're saying
to yourself, you
know what, I like Prometheus, I
like the Prometheus ecosystem,
I want to keep what
I have already,
I just want to outsource the
hard part of metric storage
and retrieval scaling, then
Managed Service for Prometheus
is the product for you.
Another way to think of this
might be, how much do you
want to be managed?
So with Managed
Service for Prometheus,
you get scalable
collections, global queries,
and long-term retention included
as a managed service, of course
with open-source interfaces.
Whereas with Cloud Monitoring
and GKE Workload Metrics,
you also get alert
management, dashboarding,
and unified metrics, logs,
and traces as managed services
as well.
Remember, because we're
using the same backend
and share a lot of the same
APIs, swapping between these
is pretty easy.
So you're never locked
into your decision.
You can choose the best solution
for you at any given time.
We are in preview right now.
We expect to be in
general availability
sometime early next year.
But we would love to
have you in preview.
You can sign up at
g.co/cloud/managedprometheus.
Once again, that's
So I'm going to turn
it over to Bartosz
now to talk about
OpenX's journey
with Managed Service for
Prometheus in preview.
BARTOSZ JAKUBSKI: Hi, my
name is Bartosz Jakubski,
and I'm a senior DevOps
Engineer at OpenX.
OpenX is a global
advertising exchange.
We handle over 200 billion
dynamic requests per day.
In 2019, we completed our
move from on-premises servers
to GCP.
Before moving to cloud,
we've had a custom monitoring
solution which is
based on Graphite,
and use Grafana now
for visualization.
We've used migration to
GCP as an opportunity
to update our monitoring stack
to Prometheus-based solution.
We're a global company.
So our monitoring
spans many GKE clusters
in multiple GCP regions
on three continents.
And right now we ingest over
350,000 samples per second.
We do use Cloud
Monitoring too, mainly
for metrics from
services managed by GCP.
When it comes to
Prometheus, we run
what I'd call a pretty standard
global Prometheus setup.
We use Thanos for
long-term storage
of metrics and global view.
We do use Grafana with about
100 dashboards right now.
And majority of our
other team works on data
from more than one GKE cluster.
So it's usually quite global.
And we store about two
years of metrics right now.
We really do like our stack.
Grafana, Prometheus, and
Thanos work well together
in the cloud.
Most importantly, it just works.
But there are some issues.
Running full kind of stack can
be quite an involved process.
You can see here a list
of Thanos components
that are running in our
global observability cluster.
You have to deploy, manage,
and monitor all of them.
In some cases, like
with Thanos start,
you have to manually
shard instances by time
to ensure they won't
run out of memory
and performance
will be adequate.
Scaling, managing
resource requirements,
modifying sharding
configuration,
is something we have
to do regularly.
Just keeping the lights
on does require work.
For example,
Kubernetes upgrades may
require modifications and
manifests for our components.
There's always
some effort needed.
We do have some
performance issues.
Some of them could be solved
on modifying our setup.
But again, it needs time
and resources to do so.
Due to a large amount
of components involved,
our global alerting
and monitoring
is a bit more fragile
than we'd like.
Also, for global setup,
intercluster connectivity
is required.
It is another piece of
cloud infrastructure
that you have to set
up and secure yourself.
Also, more components
and more involved setup
means that more
knowledge or more time
is required to make
changes or fix issues.
Why we decided to use Managed
Service for Prometheus
in preview.
First, as a company,
we are always
interested in reducing
complexity and maintenance
burden.
One way to achieve that is
by using managed services
instead of rolling out and
maintaining our own ones.
Another reason is Prometheus
query language compatibility.
This is a big
selling point for us.
Complete migration to
any other query language
would require a major effort.
And ability to run
unmodified queries
makes the move possible.
Self-managed collector
is just Prometheus.
You just deploy it like you
deploy your regular Prometheus.
It can run alongside
your Prometheus.
And to do so, it only
requires small changes
in existing configuration.
So we installed collectors
in our production clusters,
gathered some data, added
a data source to Grafana,
and we got the same
graph basically.
So it turns out that Grafana
dashboards indeed do work.
We do use more advanced
PromQL queries in some places.
And their compatibility
is pretty good too.
So what opportunities for OpenX
Managed Service for Prometheus
provides.
This is a simplified
diagram of components
that we are running in our
global monitoring stack.
If we were to move to Managed
Service for Prometheus,
in transitioning period, when
we will still need access
to our older data in
cloud storage bucket,
some components can
already be eliminated.
Once we are fully migrated to
Managed Service for Prometheus,
most of the components will
disappear with only Prometheus
collectors remaining.
This reduction in complexity
will get us some time back.
We will no longer need to adjust
storage volumes and resource
requests.
There will be no need to
modify sharding in Thanos start
instances.
Fewer components
means fewer incidents
caused by problems in alerting
and monitoring system.
Last but not least,
better integration
with Cloud Monitoring
would allow us not only
utilize Cloud Monitoring
tools like SLO alerting,
but would also simplify
and streamline access
to metric data.
No more combining two query
languages in single graph
in Grafana to combine our
application metrics with,
for example, load
balancer metrics.
Thank you for letting me
share my OpenX Prometheus
story with you.
Now back to Lee.
LEE YANCO: Thank you, Bartosz.
Once again, we would love
to have you for the preview.
You can sign up at
g.co/cloud/managedprometheus.
Thank you for watching.